hello everyone and welcome back to the
1972 wheelchair Championship match
between Boris idiot Spassky and the
robert james fisher now if you've been
with us so far you know that the result
is 10 and half to seven and half so
Fisher is still three points in the lead
and even though most of the previous
games were extremely competitive and
Spassky really tried his best he's
really playing much better than in the
first half of the match still it is
without success and a lot of the
previous games who were drawn but as the
games are very fierce on the board the
war of the board is still going on mr.
Richard Stein who was the legal
representative of mr. Chester Fox has
arrived in Iceland as we've already
mentioned and he came to Bobby's hotel
even though Bobby was sleeping but he
wanted to inform him that they will be
suing him for 1 million seven hundred
and fifty thousand dollars that's
approximately the amount that mr.
Chester Fox will lose because the Fisher
does not allow any of the games to be
filmed for now they've only been allowed
to film in Game one and Game eight so
that's really only two games that's
really not not a lot and it's well the
Icelandic Chess Federation will have to
deal with that as he already filed a
lawsuit in Iceland but for the other
half of the price the fifty thousand
pounds that were contributed to the
prize fund by James Slater for that mr.
Richard Stein will have to go to Britain
and file a lawsuit there as well but
Fisher was not very impressed by this
and he doesn't even get up he was still
just sleeping and I guess he decided to
deal with this later after the match but
it's interesting as Richard Stein said
he did not want after Fisher wins this
game wouldn't win this match and he most
likely will as he's I mean still three
points in the lead he doesn't want at
the price fund to disappear somewhere in
a Swiss bank account while mr. Chester
Fox needs his money but you know it's
really I guess it's really hard to play
a match when even if you know that after
you win the match over the board
with all that money your assets your
bank account everything will be frozen
and I mean what will you do but still
official was not very impressed and he
just wanted to play the game also the
Fisher's advocate mr. Fred Kramer all
again filed an appeal that the first two
thousand and fifty seats and be removed
and that no one is allowed to sit there
but as Fischer again didn't sign this a
lot of Schmidt simply disregarded it and
but he was also lucky because it was a
it was a very nice Sunday you know a
really sunny day in Reykjavik which
really doesn't happen a lot so a lot of
people went outside and not all that
many people even came to this game so
that's you know a bit luck for both of
them as all of the all of the seats were
available in the front rows so that
suited the Soviets but no one set there
which suited favorite side so that being
said some back story before we start the
game as poss he has the white pieces and
he opens with E for as we've already
mentioned and Fischer like in the 13th
the game goes for the aliens defense
with Knight to f6 but as a theme of this
match has been that Fischer will not
repeat a same line of the opening twice
it will be interesting to see what he
goes for in this game we have E 5 nights
2d 5d 4d 6 and now comes nice to f3 and
ok in the 13th game he played the g6 and
for this game Fischer played Bishop to
g4 Spassky obviously prepared something
as he did lose this game I would the
white pieces so he brought something new
for this game but Fischer doesn't want
to repeat he goes for Bishop to g4 and
ok Bishop to e2 we have E six castles by
Spassky and now Bishop to e7 and here h3
this is h3 sort of a new move here prior
to this game in this position each
captures and these six was played the
c-4 was played but Spassky wants to make
use of this H to remove as it will be
played sometimes in the future so now he
he wants to play it without spending
time as it comes with an attack against
the bishop on g4 we have Bishop to h5
and only now c4 Knights to b6 and now
it's the c3 face of castles we have
Bishop to e3 and now comes b5 I got a
nice move by Fisher he doesn't want to
allow nice to see six if he continues
development then captures captures and
the d5 is coming and he doesn't like
this position for black and the he
shouldn't it's it's a you know too much
space grabbing for white after Bishop to
e3 we have the five official clauses
disposition and he wants to achieve this
French like structure c5 may be coming
also at some point but with one
important difference that his light
square bishop is already nicely
developed on h5 unlike in the French
word you have to figure out what to do
with it later and here we have c5 also a
possibility for spots who was b3 which
takes away da 4 and C 4 squares for
Fischer's night but he prefers c5 and
now after this point has been pushed to
c5 Fischer decides to take away this
knight on f3 as it's a very important
defender of the d4 and d5 squares so
Bishop captures on f3 and here we have a
burst of captures on f3 if you try
something like C captures and b6 like an
in-between move it will be a very hard
to actually do something with white here
after Bishop captures ball captures on
c7 Bishop captures on d1 pawn captures
with a promotion to a queen will capture
sandy 8 and now rook F capture sandy 1
it's not really something you can push
for more than a draw here with the white
pieces and Spassky really doesn't need a
win so Bishop captures on f3 and now
comes Knight to c4 this entire French
likes a structure with black and this
whole setup is not is not something new
Fischer actually took it from the
Women's World Chess Championship match
that was played between Allah Kushner
and the nona gaprindashvili in 1969 but
in that game a knight c8 was played a
move would the knight back but here
Fischer goes for Knight to c4 and ok
Spassky after giving the position some
consideration decides to go for b3 he
forces Knight captures Bishop but this
will give him a semi-open F file so ok
we have Knight captures on e3 f captures
on e3 and now b6 glitch mentions that
the
this b6 move it seems like black is
doing perfectly fine but white is still
ahead in development and he he says that
perhaps Fischer is reaching for too much
here with this b6 move but okay as
possibly goes efore and he shows that
Fischer now definitely does have to deal
with this and that he doesn't have time
to play whatever he wants on the Queen
side as he captures on d5 is a pretty
big threat in the pond denied and the
bishop are attacking in the d5 square
and also by playing b6 Fischer opened up
this diagonal from the bishop to the
rook so he has to close at the c6 and
now comes b4 if you try it captures on
d5 immediately then after C captures and
before you will get this Knight to c6
move black gets a very nice development
the knight comes into the game with
tempo and all is well for black
so after c6 we have before immediately
by Spassky and now B captures on c5 b
captures on c5 and now Queen to a5
Fischer doesn't like the calm Knight to
d7 so he wants to play actively he
develops the the Queen while attacking
the undefended knight on c3 and here is
a position that a lot of players have
dwelled on over over the years in this
position as the knight is attacked as
possibly decided to play Knight captures
on d5 and a lot of a lot of people said
that it was there were much better moves
here for example a move like Queen to e1
was mentioned and now that this
definitely is a threat because now knife
captor Sun d5 comes with an attack on
the Queen but also threatening Knight
captures on e7 with check so a lot of
problems for blacks to deal with so
after black plays something like between
back to d8 only now black wastes two
moves which is not something you want to
do in a World Championship match so most
likely this would not be played and it
would be it would definitely be an
improvement here one one idea black
might go for his Bishop captures on c5
after pawn captures Queen captures with
check King to h1 d4 black already gets a
nice pass pawn and perhaps he can create
some complications here but the Queen to
you quaintly one definitely would be a
nice move and they said that
this would in fact have been better but
Casper Oh for example in his fourth
volume of the book my great predecessors
says that night captures and d5 is not a
problem because well there is a reason
to this now the night cannot be captured
if C captures then he captures pawn
captures Bishop captures I mean you have
three connected pawns in the center two
of them are passed pawns and the bishop
is already attacking the rook on a8
there's no way to defend it or block it
you have to give up the night so a
commercial captures it's not really a
peace sacrifice at all d5 is coming and
white white is winning here on the other
hand after Knight captures on d5 by
Spassky the other idea is he captures on
d5 but it's not that much better after
each chapter Sun d5 and 97 for example
you try to develop now comes d6 Bishop
to g5 and now comes the Bishop captures
and c6 attacking the rook and the knight
rook blocks
Oroku defends Knight captures rook
captures and now c6 and again White will
be very much winning here because these
passports are simply monsters but there
is one move that makes Knight to d5 not
so great and it is the move Fischer
played and that is Bishop to g5 and now
after a fresher play Bishop to g5 you
realized that the bishop is controlling
a lot of the squares that night can use
to retreat so the knight cannot use any
of these squares to retreat and as you
can see the Queen is guarding the knight
from the other side of the board so all
of these squares are taken by the bishop
and all of these squares are regarded by
the Queen so the knight has no retreat
squares now Spassky has to figure out
how to get his Knight out of here and
here is Posse played Bishop to h5 he
wastes one move by moving the bishop now
he frees the f4 square the rook is now
guarding f4 so the this retreat can now
be played but
Kasparov in his migrated predecessors
says that this is in fact the move that
specific could have played better
90 d5 is not the problem here instead of
Bishop to h5 Kasparov suggested Queen to
d3 and Kasparov gives the variation
night to a6 and after that h4
at this pawn sacrifice Bishop captures
an h4 and now the knight can retreat on
e3 but later it was later they found
that after Barb's idea Queen to d3 you
can actually go for a capture some d5
and grab the night he captures and now
Knight to a6 and now after d6 you will
have this Knight captures on c5 pawn
captures Queen captures and see if I
would check King to h1 and now rook to
e8 and that black will again be alright
here but you know it's not all that
really important because it's important
what the players played over the board
in 1972 in this game 19 not what you
know a lot of really strong players
found post mortem and what the engines
say about this position today but okay
after this Bishop to g5 move by Fischer
we have bushel to h5 by Spassky now
forcing Fischer to capture the night we
have pawn captures on d5 and now comes
Bishop captures on f7 a very important
move rook captures rook captures and now
Fischer cannot recapture here if King
Carter's here then Queen captures Queen
to h5 is winning whatever black plays if
you move the king then Queen to d8 will
be checkmate if you block with a g6 then
comes Queen captures on h7 with check
King yet Queen captures on g6 King be 7
and he captures on b5 it's completely
winning position for white you can
simply start by capturing here the row
can come to be one to f1 you can go all
the way up and deliver checkmate it this
way and lastly but of course not leastly
after Queen to h5 if the King simply
moves team to e7 or something you will
simply play Queen Queen characters and
g5 and then again continued the king
card or if he doesn't if he goes for
example to a fate again it's the same
thing but now first you bring the rock
into the game Rock f1 check King moves
and now again you start a very nice King
Khan King moves Queen f8 check King c7
Rock f7 check at night has the block
Queen d6 check King b7 Rock captures
came to see it and now you will deliver
checkmate after Queen to c6 King moves
and rook to be seven will be checkmate
so after this group to have
seven Fisher does not have the luxury of
capturing the rock first he plays Queen
to d2 and now because the pawn on d4 is
hanging with check Spassky has no other
option but to accept the Queen trade
Queen captures and e2 was played with
our Bishop captures and only now rook to
f1 the threat is now a rock to f8 check
for Spassky Knight to c6 now the other
Fischer's rock is guarding the f8 square
and here well if you look at the pieces
Foskey has Fischer has a rook a knight
and the bishop against two Broke so
definitely black is better here but
Spassky has this huge bone formation in
the center so it captures on d5
we have ecat force on d5 and now rook to
d7 going after the black pawn Bishop to
e3 going after the base of the pawn
chain we have King to h1 as the King was
in check and now Bishop captures on d4 e
six now not allowing the pond to be
captured and now Bishop to e5 taking
away the c7 square from whites rook we
have rook captures on d5 rook to e8 now
and now look to e1 with a double attack
against the bishop on e5 and now rook
captures on e6 look to d6 and now King
to f7 defending or you can try it rook
captures on d6 but still after C
captures king - the king to f7 now you
have to find rook to c1 the move that
holds nice to the edge hook the c7 Chirk
King to e6 rook to e7 check King
characters and now rook captures an 87
and white white will be able to hold
this
so after rook to d6 instead King to f7
was played by Fisher and now comes rope
captures on c6 rook captures and rook
captures an e5 so now after all is said
and done spassky's now up upon but it's
a rook endgame where were your up
opponent it will be very hard to push
here for something more than a draw King
to have six attacking the rook rook to
d5 and now King to e6
rope to h5 we have h6 defending the pawn
king to h2 and now rook to a6 and here
we have c6 rope captures and c6 if you
play rook captures on a - of course
you'll see how white wins this route
five and now there is no way to prevent
queening here King Disick simply see
seven characters and the white will get
a queen into the game so I foresee six
rock captors on c6 was played with a
rope to a five and now a six the brook
is not defending the pawn on e6 King the
g3 we have King to f6 King to f3 looked
the c3 check King to have two and have
to rope the C to check the players
agreed to a draw and the Fisher is still
three points in the lead after game 19
the result is now 11 to 8 and it will be
very hard for Spassky to get back into
the game not not being able to convert
another game with the white pieces into
more it's something more than a draw but
it's not over will will definitely enjoy
more games and see how it all goes
so yeah I would like to thank Pascal
Bruno Christopher pain Goran radish and
Illyria soft skin for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and hopefully I'll see you soon
with some more interesting content and
make sure the first thing you will see
in the description below is the link to
my interview with Jacques Roquefort
cheese bass just bass India so give that
you know a check as well thank you all
and I'll see you soon